[Music]
and there we go
another trumpowski car played that
yesterday
and was not very successful with it he
had a bad position
but i suppose he's improved queen to b6
by mvl attacking the pawn straight away
in the previous game ikara did something
like windy too obviously this would lose
in this position
all right hikaru must win
so he's lost the first game of the
tiebreak he has to win this game or he
loses
the match to mbl which would be
okay
so they're just developing their pieces
knight to h4 hikaru
going after mbl's light squared bishop
bishop g6 is the typical response here
to make sure that the h file is opened
up bishop to e4 first the key for mvl he
wants to trade the bishop on his own
terms
so if white takes then at least mbl gets
his knight to a good square by the way
something like this could happen so
hikara going a4 going on the other side
of the board
he's going to try to expand his control
over the queen side mbl stops him in his
tracks
car could well not entirely car could
also push the pawn to a5
you know why is he choosing the
trompowsky because it's a pretty
unbalanced opening and guarantees
an interesting position and uh he strays
away from mvl's field of expertise the
night or
the grunfelds he doesn't want to get
caught up in some sort of preparation
which is completely understandable which
is completely understandable
yeah trumpowski is not as theoretical of
an opening
first of all every opening now is
theoretical but the trompowski is not as
theoretical
as some of the other ones carlos and
geary by the way gary playing the
sicilian
carlson going c3 very solid up opening
the c3 sicilian if if geary manages to
win this game with black i will be
beyond impressed honestly so we're not
anticipating that so we are watching
three games simultaneously carlson geary
the game
four which if carlson does not lose then
he wins the match up
we are going to start watching wesley
against rajaba
sorry five games and we're going to be
watching also uh of course
nepo against aronian neither of those
games have started so let's continue
watching mbl against cicaro
and we have an opposite colored bishop
position where hikaru has managed to
introduce a defect into mvl's pawn
structure but
this pawn on e4 is both a strength and a
weakness
because look at the pawn on e4 it is
limiting the knight on h4 from getting
back into the game
i like what mbl is doing here very solid
position chuck
33 44 55 thank you for the sub
happy thanksgiving to you too is g5 a
move it is
but then the knight's going to dip back
to g2 and you've got to be very careful
about weakening your king's side mvl
trading going knight to d5
notice that if the queen takes on e4 mvl
has hooked himself to that pawn on b2
this is a great idea by mvl
and if knight g2 he can go f5 and defend
his pawn with another pawn that's the
most reliable way of defending
let's see what a power does here he does
go knight two he couldn't allow bishop
takes h45 has happened
hmm okay
okay
queen b1
queen b3 mvl expanding his control over
the position bishop g5
a5 but what about knight before ladies
and gentlemen what about knight before
doesn't this trap the rook if you take
the knight i take the rook
he's done it night before by mbl this is
a disaster for hikaru his rook has
nowhere to go
then if you take then queen takes c2 and
the rook is lost
oh my lands and he's given up the
exchange this is a losing position for
hikaru out of the opening
and mvl has to only not not lose he can
draw
it's not over it's never over hikaru we
know how he defends
but now then the simple knight d3 forces
more trades because if you take i take
and again
as soon as the queen leaves b1 black
takes b2
so mvl with a critical position here
he's got to capitalize on this
but knight d3 i think is the simplest
way to force further trades
and he's gone knight d5 so he's gone
back to d5 this is also fine obviously
jam jam with five gifted to the
community holy smokes here he comes
here comes the man himself thank you jim
jim really appreciate it
all right
so f3 by icaru he's trying to open up
the position he's trying to create some
chances
hikaru has to not only not lose this but
he's got to win this
that's what makes this so incredibly
difficult ambient exchange
for no compensation he drops the screen
back to b5
going after the spawn of course c4 not
possible you just take the pawn
rook to e1 by ikaro doing a good job
opening up the e file doing what he can
the move rook d6 though seems very
likely here
and um it looks like black is uh black
is
is more than fine here he's he's still
winning
and mvl has to manage the fact that he
can draw this game
let me refresh the board to see if the
clocks start ticking i know that's
annoying
yes okay we're good now the clocks are
ticking rook to a queen a2 by ikaro he's
building up a time advantage threatening
rook takes c6 this is not over yet
we all know that hikara is more than
capable of climbing back in these types
of positions
and i think mvl is beginning to let this
one slip
king to h8 but now bishop h5 is possible
and knight h4 akara starts getting his
pieces out
after winning the exchange mvl starting
to
starting to um let this one go
bishop h5 rook fe rookie six i mean
king h8 just seems very superficial and
there comes bishop h5
regard is not going to give you two
chances maybe
what nbl needs to do and rookie 70s
blunder knight h4 now mvl is worse
this is unreal this is horrible play by
mvl but incredibly
amazing resistance by hikaru who now has
bishop g6 and bishop f5
not to take anything away from nakamura
he's missed it knight g6
oh that would have been a big chance
bishop g6 ladies and gentlemen
and if king g8 bishop takes f5 if you
notice this pin
i think he had this and now this is a
big
breath of fresh air for mvl though he
again gives up f6 but he wants knight f6
there
i don't know what's going on here i
don't know what's going on here rookie 6
knight f6 i guess is the idea
one second
okay one sec 95 no
hikaru decides not to take the pawn
instead he goes to f5 now if i were mvl
i would try to move this king away from
the line of fire
of the bishop the other thing that's
important to point out here
is if c4 you can just sack on c4 or you
can go queen b4
counter attacking the rook so c4 isn't
strictly speaking a threat mbl has done
it
getting to g8 mm-hmm
well i'm into this so let's see what
happens i think nvl doing a really good
job of protecting this
hey caro had a big chance there that he
missed if
if my calculation wrong again i'm not
using the computer i'm just looking at
it from my own end
i don't know what's going on here this
is a very complex position icarus
obviously sinking his knight on g6 now
what how does mbl play this does he try
to protect this phone does he try to go
for active defense he goes back to h7
his idea if you take on e6 mvl goes
knight f6 intercepting the rook's
defense over the
over the the knight and if the bishop
moves obviously king takes 36 but bishop
b2 is possible i think that might be a
key detail
that we'll see if one of them spots this
i don't know if that's even good for
white or not
um i'm getting all the right moves okay
great
so rook takes e6 is what's coming to my
mind knight f6 bishop e2
and then you could have an end game of
this kind where yes
white is down in exchange but he's got a
pawn and he's got a massive pawn
structure here so hikaru definitely
contemplating rook takes e6 here
i can guarantee you that's what he's
calculating will he play the move
i don't see an alternative i i just
don't see what else he can do
either other than rook takes e6 and he
has done it
so what we're going to see now my guess
is knight f6 bishop b2 is forced i'm
pretty
sure bishop e2 seems absolutely forced
and then it's up to mbl does he trade
queens does he move his queen bishop e2
happens queen d5 seems to be the most
natural
it's happened um takes on d5 takes on d5
and knight e5 so exactly as we
anticipated knight to h4
by the way also very interesting you
could okay bishop oh you don't even have
to move the knight so bishop d3 and work
f7 defending the pawn knight e5 comes to
mind
chasing the rock away white is
definitely calling the shots now an
incredible comeback by hikaru
an incredible comeback by hikaru now how
do we make sense of this position
let's count the pawns five pods for
black and six bonds for white so white's
got a pawn for the exchange
but if you look at the actual placement
of the pieces white's got
massive initiative here attacking f5
attacking the 90s pushing black's pieces
around none of them are defended
and if you go 97 you walk into rook d7
forking the knight in the pawn so knight
e3 mbl trying to scramble
you don't want to go king f2 here
because the knight can then win the pawn
on b2 that's gotta
that's something you gotta watch out for
but he car just says okay let's leave
that knight stranded
and let's go after what black's queen
side bonds i think black is losing here
i think black is losing here and this is
an insane turnaround
from hikaru and mbl mvl with a winning
position out of the opening rook d6
okay um i wonder what's behind that move
i guess knight d7 is a potential threat
here
that's not really a threat is that rook
on dc okay and be all going back to c8
mvl wants to go knight to d1 he his only
active idea i think is to go after
somehow go after these pawns
okay now rook king f2 why did the car
put a rook on b6 so that knight d1
no longer wins the pawn on b2 now mvl's
gonna have to drop it back to d5
and back to e7 it's exactly what's
happened any car could
could add the tabasco sauce at any
moment with g4 he adds it with knight t7
if you go rook to e8 you walk into a
discovery
i think this knight is relocating it's
relocating from
from e5 to c5 and uh
that's going to put the damper on any
attempt sets what he does
the rook on c7 now can't move right
because the knight is contesting and
attacking the pawn on b7 mbl trying to
shift around his pieces
he's trying to find the best defensive
posture but ikaro can go b4
he can pull the net on black's pieces
yup g6 by mbl trying to buttress the
pawn on f5
and uh this is i don't know i mean icaru
with 45
seconds which is not a lot of time in a
position like this here's the problem
the computer might say white's better
but from a practical perspective asikara
trying to undermine
white black spawns does mbl go h5 but
then 96 mbl trying scrambling keeping
his pieces defended
hikaru is going to have to choose a
moment to quote uncle go for it
and he just did and he's going for it in
a big way but 96 there's rook takes c4
maybe you drop the bishop back to b3
maybe you play bishop b3 or even bishop
a2
to prepare the move knight e6 but and
that has it's a little bit slow
mvl is also a beast at defending these
positions yup that's what he does
now here's the thing if you go knight e6
then nbl can still capture on c3 and he
can counter-attack the bishop so 96
isn't really a threat
question is what does mbl do g5 comes to
mind but then h5
continuing to bang in those nails into
black's coffin
rook to d7 now seems pretty automatic
don't take on b7 because you give up the
knight on c3
car under 30 seconds he's gonna have to
make a move this is going to be very
hard to win with almost no time on the
clock my guess is rook d7 has to be
played he does
what does mbl do now does he move his
knight away does he play knight to g8
knight to c8 okay this is a must win
bishop to d5 and the car going now after
black spawns and 96 and he's going to
win on a fork deliver to mvl's rook
and if he always resigned what a
comeback by hikaru incredible
unbelievable and just absolutely
insane the fact not only that he didn't
lose the position after the night before
but the fact that he won it
and it seemed like the turnaround
occurred within the scope of
four or five moves and i honestly can't
believe that mbl did not play knight d3
in this position this seemed like a
an automatic kind of move which would
have greatly reduced
white's chances to win the game because
it would have forced him to give up his
bishop and now they go on to their
armageddon
to armageddon they go to armageddon
and uh in the meantime aronian and nepal
playing their first game of the blitz
playoff
carlson and geary gary has succeeded in
making this crazy
but who is it crazy for i think black is
just worse
so this is incredible and icaru is
definitely the favorite in the
armageddon an unbelievable turnaround
and yeah we all know how he can defend
but
mvl definitely with a golden opportunity
there to put the match away
wow so definitely
something that is going to haunt him
tonight we'll try to stay for the for
the interesting action carlson is
definitely better i don't think he's
going to lose
now this position and gary again has to
win to carry this through to the
blitz playoffs so we'll see mbl and
nakamura are on their way
buckle up seat belts fastened and
mandatory ladies and gentlemen here we
go
here we go and another one of these
italians we've seen this opening in
every one of their white games and
they're playing so fast that's just how
the transmission is
they're repeating the line from what
they just had i wonder if they both
looking
i wonder if they both looked up uh this
line and whose preparation was better
generally in these positions white's
better uh
because white's got a freer position
he's got control of a lot of key squares
i'm going to disable the alerts
temporarily
uh and and he's attacking the rook so
hikaru now with a key dilemma
he goes knight before now mvl shifts his
knight over to d4
that blockading squad we've talked about
many times
okay nikaru needs a draw to win the
rules of the armageddon white
as you can see white has five minutes
black is four minutes but
a win a draw is a win for black
obviously that's the odds and
now rook c8 i don't know yeah looks like
he car's got a great position here
maybe queen e3 queen f4 because rook c3
is a pretty serious threat now is there
increment i don't think so
i don't think there's any increment
which means that flagging is definitely
a part of the equation queen to b4
by hikaru he's putting the pressure the
heat on the knight on d4
okay no increment so flagging is on the
table
which means that that's part of the
reason why this is such a
big odds queen f4 the car's bishop is
attacked he's got to move it
where does he move it he moves it to d7
i would go rook 81 if i were mvl
trying to get my rook in the game
okay
hmm
okay let's see
and be all thinking i don't like his
position
at all i think that it's very hard to
recover in a4 hikaru doing a really good
job
putting the pressure on the queen side
he's chipping away from the other side
i'm not sure where mbl is going to get
his chances he's got a nice knight
but the point of a4 and he trades queens
so knight takes f4 now is interesting
and we're going to see some sort of an
end game
where it is true that the knight is good
but now rook c2 comes to mind maybe you
attack the pawn on f2
it's frozen no it's not it's not frozen
um i don't think it is
yeah uh and bishop b6 by hikaru okay so
he stabilizes the situation he does have
two minutes and 25 seconds
that's going to be an important thing
i'm going to refresh the board so the
clock starts ticking for you guys
and uh this is equal rook to c4 mvl no
this is not winnable
and and nicaragua is going to carry this
match
and uh he's going to carry this match
and mvl missing the golden opportunity
in the previous game unless emile can
find a way to flag him or trick him
uh board is frozen still sorry sorry
yeah it is frozen now
damn it worst possible moment okay this
is the position
guys i got it this is the position so
now we're good i think okay so he's got
to keep the pieces on the board maybe
get the knight back to d4
but now d4 i think this move is key
let's see if carl plays it
d4 forcing the trade
and uh this is just a dead draw he does
it
he does it knight d4 now rook d8 is also
possible you can go rook d bishop takes
a2
mbl's gonna have to go for the flag here
and he's gonna have to find a way
to to to not trade
every single piece because if he car is
gonna have like a minute and a half in a
you know rook versus rook position
flagging is absolutely on the
table if i were mvl i would try to keep
pieces on the board i would go rook b1
here
because the more pieces are on the board
the more icaru has to think
and that's exactly what mvl does okay
so let's see what happens here hikaru
thinking every second that passes is a
golden second he's got a minute and 39.
this is going to be close because mvl is
slightly better here he's the one
pushing
but he car the position is definitely
still drawn at the same time rook to b2
minute and a half now for hikari he's
got the pass pawn he defends it mbl's
got the good night
and he's got a nice little pawn
structure going here on the on the king
side this is a dead draw
but a minute extra now for mvl who's got
to win this game
well it's not that he allowed these
trades he had no choice
he had no choice in this position maybe
knight to c2
but no i doubt that he's going to pull
this out because he carries just too
fast and too accurate
and that last game was his biggest
chance that that
last game was a huge chance and he car
trades the rooks he's gone rook a2
i apologize for the choppy transmission
that's just how it's coming through
knight to c6 mbl stops the pawn
bishop d5 would meet with knight e7 so
some bite to the position remaining uh
but this is a draw i mean
ikaro just has to approach with his king
but mvl can approach with his
f5 bishop b3 f5 okay
um now king to d4 kc5 the problem is yup
bishop to d1 tying himself to the pawn
now g5 is a very strong move
and that shatters any hopes that nbl may
have had of winning this game
he takes in g5 h5 is possible he takes
total liquidation this is going to be a
draw and
hikaru is going to carry this match and
all credit to him
mvl with a huge miss in the last game
that is true
but gotta tip your hat to ikaro for for
that uh
for that defensive uh display and it's
not over yet mbl trying his best
under a minute now for hikaru but it's
it's enough time here to make the draw
it's enough time here to make the draw
um but hikara's got to be careful
because if you if you
oh wait a minute careful e6
oh this is cool whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
is this a draw
is this a draw this is probably a draw
because b3
b3 and b2 this is a typical technique
yeah it's a draw it's a oh but kg2
wait a minute is it a draw this might be
a win
knight to c3 wait a second who's winning
this might be a draw this is very these
positions are always very close but it's
probably a draw
it's probably a draw knight b1
it's a draw it's still a draw because
the king always comes to g4 in this
situation
i would go knight b1 here and then king
d4 and black by the skin of his teeth
that is very karo cutting it very close
king f4 king d3983 king c3 this is a
draw
but mvl has several attempts here knight
a3 maybe
it's a draw but the time situation these
guys got to be very careful
he's got to be very careful but now king
f5
okay so now i would go king f2
okay king f2 the problem for for mvl
and it's a draw they've agreed to draw
it says draw because they've repeated
moves
that was one and it's official that was
that was one that was two and that was
three it's a three-time repetition
the game has ended in a drop and there
is simply
no way to win this position the pawn
ties the knight down
as soon as white king goes after black's
pawn then king g4 comes
and you win the pawn he carries knew
this position and uh it is a draw it is
an objective draw
and yeah there's just no way to win so
an incredible
incredible display good morning
i hope everyone is well
um good afternoon to some of you yeah so
we're uh we're tuning in to round three
of the skilling open
we have magnus nepo in front of us and
nakamura so
game three in front of us as well um so
we're gonna be watching those games and
then time permitting
i'll see if i can get some blitz in as
well i'm also
i'm also eating some breakfast i hope
you guys don't mind um
i'll be muting myself just to chew and
stuff
yesterday at evening we hit 4 000 subs
for the first time i'm still writing the
high of that
i have no words to describe the events
of last evening
and i'll i'll thank everyone properly
later but in the meantime let's jump
into the games
so it it it appears to me thank you nace
delight for the prime
recovery goes great i'm pain free
knock on wood i'm feeling feeling great
this morning
so you know
i don't think we could either um
yesterday was thanksgiving so
people expressed their gratitude to me
and that made me blush but i
feel like words cannot express my
gratitude to this community
but anyways um we we have
nakamura so i think wesley's leading by
a point and carlson is leading by a
point
all right
and i hope you guys don't mind if i do a
little light eating
i'll be muting myself temporarily for
like a couple seconds at a time
okay so
what we have here in nakamura
so is an interesting position we had a
well we had a tarash atari count again
but with c takes d4 this is actually a
very underestimated line i never found
an advantage in this line
see the interesting thing about this
line is that it it isn't
popular but it's it's actually very
robust and i was not able to find an
advantage
uh for white in this line
and it seems like wesley did a good job
equalizing just bishop before
94 ruined white's pawn structure and
this is actually a very typical
structure
where black has a black is a deficiency
on d5
i mean that's an isolated queen's pawn
and if we look at the square in front of
it it's very well controlled
by white spawns but
on the other hand um if we look at
white's pawn structure on the queen side
that's also very deficient
white's got these two isolated ponds
which are kind of weak
um and and the two whoops and the two
just balance themselves out
uh so maybe white is a tiny bit better
here because he's got a very active
knight maybe queen c2
to threaten checkmate this comes to mind
and and you force a little weakness in
in black's king's side with g6 but but
now bishop f5 is a threat
uh and that pins the queen to the rook
so i'm not sure yeah hikaru is going to
have to generate some chances uh
of course against mvl you lost the first
day's matchup and then came back in a
big way
i mean i don't like i personally
one of my biggest pet peeves is over
overly loud
really loud yawns that's from another
thing i don't know if anybody knows that
reference
but overly loud eating noises like
chewing with the mouth open
i'm sensitive to the fact that that can
be very annoying uh so that's why i move
myself and eat
um okay so let's check in on nepo
against carl's
whoo it looks like nepo is
succeeding here two minutes and 40
seconds for carlson and he seems to be
worse he's down upon
nepal's got connected passers this seems
like a grunfeld's gone completely wrong
for magnus
um hello gm hess look at look at this
man
always stalking my streams i wonder who
that is
no mukbang stream no
especially with how easy it is to meet
my and that's what people want anyway
for me to shut the hell up finally
okay so we had a grunfeld
and magnus
wow nepo look at this man refusing the
draw of course magnus winning the second
game so a draw is in his favor that
would leave it with only one more game
but nepo going for it grabbing the pawn
on a2 which is very typical to sacrifice
this pun
but it seems like magnus wasn't able to
procure sufficient compensation nepo
just pushed it
nebo just said i have an extra pass pawn
i'm gonna push the hell out of it
and uh it seems like magnus is in grave
danger here
but we all know and this is just my
artificial impression i'm not a
specialist in these positions
but it seems to me that magnus's
compensation lies in the fact that
well he's got two very strong passers in
the center but they're not going
anywhere i mean if you play d6
you can't do this because the bishop's
just gonna take the rook
and if you go e6 again you drop the rook
so that's out of the question
carlson trying scrambling to keep nepo's
pieces out of his grill
queen trade offered which is in black's
favor because he's got the past pawns
i won't meet myself drinking though this
is my first day i'm allowing myself
coffee
so i'm going gonna be pretty high in a
moment i haven't had coffee in like a
week
but i figured today was a safe um
just really quickly can you have coffee
three days after a wisdom teeth removal
i'm pretty sure it's fine
and i've been taking no chances
yeah 24 hours okay we're good the
veronicas thank you for gifting to luxie
all right so we're just watching things
unfold nepo can take another pawn here
but he's got to be careful he doesn't
want to lose this fun this is the pride
the jewel
of the nile as michael douglas
wait what's that movie called romancing
the stone and then what's the second
movie called is it the jewel of the nile
anyways doesn't matter um here i go with
my 80s
movie references again but if nepo takes
on d5
then well magnus can't take here right
because takes takes rook d2 and it's
always important to know when you have a
fiance bishop there is very rare that
there's a backrank mate because you can
play bishop f8
so what exactly does magnus want to do
here i think that's what nepo is trying
to figure out
there was a jewel of the nile dude i
love those movies those movies are great
wait it was michael douglas who was who
was the female actress
um i should know that okay
um apparently nepal left the room a
while ago and the official stream is
making a drama kathleen turner
damn jesus terrible terrible terrible
trouble so nepal goes g5 very
sensible move obviously what he's trying
to do is break into white's pawn
structures that the bishop could land on
e5 which would spell death for white
and magnus can't i mean in such
situations you normally go g3
obviously you can't do that here magnus
position is collapsing completely
you don't see this very often magnus
with the white pieces dirty moves in
struggling to stay alive for a couple
more moves i think he's completely lost
and look at the time disparity as well
stop them out
i'm trying to mount my ipad and i'm
failing
okay thank you uh emil alter for the
tier one and
i'm in disbelief right now magnus does
not lose games like this very often i
mean you can try g4
maybe g but then just bishop e4 i mean
what's the big deal
magnus below two minutes wow this is
pretty impressive this calls for another
couple bites
okay we should be four going after the
pawn
but is he i mean gf rook a3
rook a3 again you can't take with the
rook because d1 is hanging if you take
with the bishop this is over
rook cannot keep both bishops defended
at the same time i'm going to take one
of them
i think ah magnus wants this he wants to
skewer the rook to the bishop
i'm eating oatmeal and but but even here
after rook d4 you're counter-attacking
white's bishop so if we consider what
happens when the smoke clears takes
takes
takes takes takes him magnus has
succeeded in eliminating the pawn but
now
into the game comes black's bishop
blacks up three pawns now this is just
over
um i think i think nepal can just play
gf uh for starters and maybe there's
something even better
that is kasparov in the picture behind
me yes
so gary kasparov hosted a bunch of
master classes in in new york
for so-called talented young players i
don't know how i made the cut
uh and this was about 2004 2005. my
youtube
banner picture is also one of my best
photos with kasparov
and it was a super um it was a super
interesting experience uh
you know the first time you lay eyes on
kasparov it's like
i mean he walks into the room and
everybody just takes out this this
breath you know oh my god kasparov
and there's this energy that accompanies
him which it's hard to explain
until you see him but this guy is a god
and everybody was absolutely starstruck
and we got a 10 donation from matterhorn
thank you
thank you for not advertising yourself
every two seconds way better commentary
than the effort well thank you i really
appreciate that you enjoy
enjoying the commentary and i apologize
for not starting it earlier
i i did want to force myself to get some
sleep
uh because i don't want to play any
games with my
with anything really um
and okay so checking back into hikaru
against wesley it looks like wesley
is in very good shape here he's got very
active pieces
uh we have an equal material and so what
happens hikaru decided to transform the
structure by taking the bishop and
breaking through with c4
wesley responded with 95 that's a very
strong move because the queen is hanging
it cannot take
so hiccaro instead well he was forced to
defend c5 and so we had a big trade
there
and we have an endgame and i think it's
an equal end game
what are the pros and cons for both
sides here well first thing that jumps
to mind right is is the rook on a6 is
very nice
it attacks e6 it holds down blackstroke
on c7
and you have a situation with a knight
against the bishop and in these
situations
you always want to weigh the pros and
cons of the knight on the bishop in the
given position
position is pretty closed so knights are
generally good in close positions but
uh if you notice black is a bunch of
pawns on light squares which means that
the bishop can
exploit them if for example hikaru plays
e4
that's that's the idea of bishop b3 he
wants to break into black's pawn chain
with e4
so something like knight c4 comes to
mind covering it with black's body
wesley's made a move knight e3 similar
and against c4 does anybody see what his
idea is
the car was made a move but just to
involve everybody what was his idea with
knight d3
um what do you mean five puns each is
still considered close
so the knight from d3 very jumpy night
boom
boom boom so you attack the rook and
then you win the pawn so hikaru
has gone h4 just expanding on the king
side biting his time making a healthy
move
a lot of people see moves like this from
gm's and they just oh you know he's got
some hidden intention i'll never
understand such a move
moves like h4 in the end game are not i
mean they are deep
at times but the reality is they're just
improving moves right you're just
you're creating some love for the king
maybe later on you're going to use this
pawn as a battering ram
to to weaken black's defenses a little
bit more
but you see this move all the time it's
sort of as my old coach would say
completing the architectural design of
the puns right it's like this move that
everybody makes in the end game
wesley could basically draw the game
with knight c5
and and and this is just a draw i mean
you have total liquidation you have a
four rook end game
and a draw so wesley's contemplating
this but if i were black i would
consider playing
for the advantage with something like
rook b8 first maybe to prepare knight c5
that's
an interesting idea or maybe just go to
b4 something like that
on the other hand wesley has a point
ahead in the match so
is it worth worth it for him to press
his luck here
uh given that he has white in the last
match game probably not
so we'll see
oh my god this happened exactly
this is exactly what happened he won
knight c5 rook a5 this is exactly what
happened
and it's gonna be a draw um
gotta uphold my name you know no but i
mean this is not
anything impressive on my part it was
just the very obvious development of the
game
um and this is going to be agreed to
draw any second
let's look at the magnus game so magnus
has managed to transform the game into
an end game
where nepo is up two pawns one of the
pawns this is the important pawn right
this is the past pawn this is the one
that's going to win him the game
hopefully for
nepo but how did magnus manage to get
this relatively okay so he somehow
yeah so this happened oh bishop e7
ah and he went he went after the pawn
this way interesting
so nepo decided to okay i'll give it up
i'll take the other one
and we have a rook end game now let's
not jump to conclusions here magnus is
down two puns
it looks like he's completely lost maybe
he is but my experience tells me that
these end games are never that easy
because
how does nepo make progress now the rook
guards the pawn
stroke can't leave e5 right if it leaves
e5
it has to go right back the king can't
really leave
g5 if it goes to f6 you're going to take
the punt i
believe it or not i mean maybe magnus is
in zuswan maybe
that's the idea because if magnus drops
his king back to
maybe he can and he does and he can just
shuffle between these two squares until
the earth turns into a supernova nepal
has realistically only one idea he's got
to walk his king over to the other side
of the board
he has to go king f5 at some point maybe
not here maybe he pushes his h1 first
at some point he's going to have to make
a run for it and the idea is going to be
to just start giving up these pawns but
to use the king to dislodge the rook
from before i don't see any other ways
to try to win this game
i i don't i respectfully disagree with
svidler i don't think it's a simple draw
um in fact i think after king f5 i mean
first of all peter has a much better
understanding of end games than i do and
let me put that out there immediately
uh let me shoot down any any people
thinking that i'm
being presumptuous i think if you should
trust anyone it's fiddler but to my eye
this doesn't look easy to draw at all i
mean what if the king just walks over to
c5 and then you start pushing the pawn
so there's clearly there's something
here that i'm missing because nepal was
thinking
and apple usually plays fast if he's
confident
well the problem is i mean if you take
rook f4 i go rook f5 and i force the
rook trade
right so it you can play and again if
you take it with the king
sorry if you take it with the king i
don't care the rook on e5 is guarding
the fifth rank you can't pass it nepo
goes rook d5 and rook c5 i
i'm not sure what i'm missing guys um
i'll be honest i i'm just not sure
why it is that nepo can't try to make a
run for it and if it's a draw there okay
then make magnus work
for it
um why not defend both pawns with rook
out five well
that's what nepo was doing but where do
you go from here remember
black needs to make progress it's not
enough to just say oh i have two extra
bones i'm awesome
like magnus is just gonna sit there and
do nothing and
you know you can take those extra two
puns and you know
you can magnus is like you can put them
where the sun doesn't shine but
eventually you'll have to make progress
and that means sacrificing one of them
but okay i think maybe king goes to f5
and
no but i mean okay maybe king goes to g5
i think it's draw but
no but you should not listen to this
naradiski he he wrote the book on end
games that i now use as toilet paper
to wipe my behind with but okay i think
maybe this is the equal draw
um all right um
that was pretty funny no but i
i mean nevo continues to think he's got
below two minute there we go what did i
tell you that
what did i tell you here he comes with
this king i told you you'd make a run
for it
okay so so i'm not crazy now if king f4
you have rook c4 track forcing the rook
trade this might still be a draw
c3 can be three five c three four notes
winning boom boom boom and you use the
pawn as a decoy you walk around take all
the pawns so
magnus has to calculate this he might
have to and rook out before there's
rockefeller so there's a rook trade
against
both ways of taking the pawn thank you
for 100 bits so magnus can't take the
pun
uh or can he maybe i've miscalculated
this but i don't think so so here here
here
here yeah this i just checked this is
winning
okay this is winning
so if magnus can't take the pawn then
that means he's got to make a wasting
move such as rook b1
but that gives black a crucial template
to advance his king further to supervise
the pawn
and the the main road well you can go
king c4 right if you give a check
you can start sidestepping the rook your
malinsky taught me this
this is the ideal position for
supervising the pawn forward because if
you continue to give checks i'll go to
b2
and then i'll start pushing the pawn so
i'm not seeing
how magnus makes a draw here uh i'll be
honest with you guys
okay let me take a couple bites as we
watch this end game unfold cicaro and so
officially have made a draw
now after the game i'll show you guys
what i do if i wanted to if i was a
serious student of the game
and i wanted to squeeze the most
instructive value out of this end game
and use
chess base i'll show you exactly what i
do to enhance my knowledge of these
positions
rookie five so again you cannot take the
pawn that's that's a key
right because rook f5 and you force the
rook trade and then the pawn end game is
very clearly winning because black's got
the outside pass pawn
which is used to distract white's king
and in the meantime black singing is
going to come in and take white's pawns
and nepo's defends his pawn he says okay
for the time being is going to keep his
pawn protected and
and that's a stop gap right the rook is
not going to remain on f5 forever i
think it's going to remain on
as long as possible to delay the process
of white
trying to inch his way forward and take
some a black spawn so i'm anticipating
king d6 here
oh look at the patience first he plays
h5
first he improves his position stops the
king's passage to g4
but eventually again he's going to have
to take the plunge and he's going to
start walking his king
let's see when that moment comes magnus
doesn't have much that he can do he
tries his best to put his body over
the king's wall king e4 hmm
so again to be very clear what i'm not
understanding here
uh from my perspective is why it is that
nepo can't give a check
and just walk his king to c5
the king is cut off from coming to e4
and then you should start supervising
the pawn's progress with the king
so there's something there that i'm
missing there's a source of counter play
i'm pretty sure
but we'll see what nepo does here he's
got below two minutes you've got to
leave yourself some time
but imagine defending this with a minute
i mean jesus h4
so he's fixing the pawns first which is
sensible i suppose
and it's not that magnus has anything
particularly useful that he can do rook
a1
careful don't go here you blunder the
rook
rook a6 and king takes f don't worry
nepal won't do that
if you're an epo fan you don't have to
worry he won't do that
yeah well rook c5 is the same idea right
you got to leave with the rook if
you want to push this pawn you you can't
let white maintain contact with your
rook
you've got to do something about that
okay um i'm not entirely sh sold on
nepo's pawn push here i'm not sure if
that does more harm or good
and uh the real sad reality is um these
end games
are among the most how should i put it
confusable end games
possible even for gm's i mean i'm
looking at this and i have no idea if
it's winning or drawn
i have no idea what the correct strategy
is and let me fill you in on something
neither does napo most probably because
and and this is no insult to him it's
just that these are very hard to study
you you how do you study this particular
end game how do you know what to do
so it's all up to guesswork and
intuition that's where these 2700s are
true geniuses they're able to figure out
what to do
without really having seen similar end
games
and even the computer can struggle to
evaluate these positions that's how
complex they are
that's how complex they are trust me on
this um don't be quick to bury these
players and say ah
i thought nepa was good look at all
these mistakes he's making this is super
confusing stuff and
it nobody really knows what they're
doing here so what's going on here
magnus has managed to relocate his rook
behind the pawn that's a huge
accomplishment for white i'm not sure
why nepo has allowed this
now if nepo goes after white's pawns
then the thing to notice here is that
all of the pawns
are are now on one flank and that means
they're a lot easier to manage for
white's king white just starts chopping
up all these pawns with his king and his
rook
you know black could go up two pawns
formally speaking but this is whoops but
this is gonna be a draw you know white
can just go after this one
uh and and it seems to me like nepo has
has
perhaps given away his biggest chances
of winning the game
maybe he go okay rook g2 but now rook b5
this is definitely a draw now
and the interesting thing is that rook
b6 first by magnus to chase the king
away first
and now you can even play yeah rook b5
so
uh you could have a position with f and
h pawns against the king
and and that is a draw you can find this
in any end game manual i can even prove
to you
that that is the case if i hunt down let
me see if i have an endgame
book at hand uh which i surprisingly
don't know where all my endgames books
went where is my copy of fundamental
chess endings that is my most prized
possession
there it is so if we look
at and this is what you would do before
the internet right you'd have a book
like this you'd say okay
i want to figure out if an end game like
this is drawn
rook versus coupons 164.
this is a book that is flies under the
radar and i highly recommend it
oh no no we want rook we want rook end
games
rook versus rook rook and pawns versus
rook 177
and uh here we go so
rook and i'm looking for rook and
coupons you have all sorts of end games
here
sharon here's rook and two pawns against
rook
and i'm looking for rook and f and h
ones it's got to be there
that's got to be there f and h bonds i
even had yep there we go
so there's mazzellus there we go gliger
smith's love look
glittery smith's and let me just see
you see that he's analyzing this end
game even i had it once and this is a
draw
so he's indicating equality
and this is not the same this is not the
same end game because here white has a
much better version of it if you if you
look
white's king has frozen the rook and
pawn in place if you go h2
you allow king g2 the rook has to move
and you take the pun
and the draw is very elementary so the
question for nepo is can he dislodge
white's king from g3 magnus says no
because he's keeping the rook on a5 this
is sort of a philidor like defense
you can't go f4 it's illegal if you move
your king away
big big whoop you know i go rook b5 and
again if you go f4
i think you can just take the pawn h2
you go back to g3 you are in time to
stop the pawn
no way to make progress and do you think
yukari would play king rook versus king
hook in this tournament
why will rook g1 i take the pawn that's
the idea but nepo is going to have to go
rook to brook
yeah so nepo's only chance is to do
this and then kg4 now what's what to
understand in this position
this one i know very i know these end
games pretty well white's easiest
defense is to go rook a8
now in such positions and those of you
familiar with rook end games you would
know that basically the philidor defense
or the third ranked defense is the
easiest way to draw such a position
there we go
but what some people don't know is there
is an alternate drawing method where you
put the rook behind the pawn
for the duration of this endgame so rook
f8 here would be a drawing move
and i can show basically the drawing
methods rook a4 there's many there's
many ways to draw this this is even
better for white because the pawn is in
anywhere near f3
uh so there's multiple methods here of
drawing this
king e3 okay this is unbelievable that
magnus pulled this off unbelief okay
this is even easier
uh king g3 because the pawn isn't even
going to f4 normally in these end games
the pawn is already on f4
so this would be not possible but here
the draw is very elementary because
black simply cannot make any progress
incredible now you just go rook b4 for
example you just you just
do nothing right and and as soon as
black's king moves away
you go back you go out to f4 and uh the
pawn is toast
you just go rook four and you win the
pawn and rook f4 oh magnus just picks
off the pawn right away king h4 and king
g5
okay king h4 here was a little bit
easier than king g5 but it's fine
thank you frostex and 200 bits from
oversoul appreciate it
this is a dead draw and they agreed to a
draw wow
an incredible incredible
comeback from magnus and that just shows
you how hard this guy is to bring down
and um one what i could do
like let's say you were to look at this
game you're like man i want to know more
about these types of end games right let
me make a search
for this pawn strike let me see if i can
find in chess space
any similar end games from chess history
it's going to be a bit of a
tall order let me see if i can do a
quick search while the games haven't
started yet to show you
how i would go about studying this type
of uh
this type of end game let me think for a
second so what we want is this
we want this and now we want
rooks and rooks and we want three pawns
for black
and two pawns for white okay
let's see
yeah so i found some similar and here we
go um so for example i can make a search
and i can tell you guys that
we had for example following game uh
which is not the same
and just give me a second please i'm
changing scenes
so this is kind of a cool use of chess
space right if you want to know
how i would train this just give me one
one second please
okay we need to make this a little bit
bigger
okay we need to make it a little smaller
and we're good bing bang boom
and now we need to make the player names
perfect and we're good so
this is not the game you're this is not
the nepo game this is a game between
two grand masters flores is a grand
master from argentina cuartos from
colombia
and they reached a very similar end game
to uh
to to the magnus now but with the
exception that black has no pawn on f4
and you can see that in this endgame
well the king was cut off and let's see
what black did here
okay you had a similar way of defending
and
and here the difference is that white
decided to use his
king to defend the pawn and use his rook
on the other side nepo or magnus
basically did the opposite
and it seems like this strategy
backfired because eventually what
happened is that the king ended up too
far away
from the pawn and it was cut off yeah it
was cut off and eventually black out the
lucina position
which is a very famous theoretical
position um
there was another so that was one
example of when that was reached there
was an even
a very old game from the 1930s
where this happened william bruger
against william winter was a very strong
player he was a famous player
but here what winter decided to go for
that end game we were talking about rook
and two
against a rook and the game ended in a
draw like these end games are not easy
to win
and uh and sorry these end games are not
easy to draw even if they're
theoretically drawn
and black managed to win this one even
though the position was drawn
so i think that where where nepo missed
his main win
was that he for some reason he see king
d6 in this position would be a good
example of what i think
is a winning move and you just you say
okay i'm gonna give up the pawns right
i don't care and i'm just gonna push my
pawn because the rook cuts off the king
and i'm not sure why he didn't do that
to be honest with you guys so
we'll see i need to run to the restroom
i'll be right back
i'm going to put on nakamura so which so
nakamura which just started i'll be
right back guys
so what do we have going on here we have
a dutch
car in a must-win situation today
mainline dutch
okay this is all basically normal g5 wow
we have a a sort of a weird structure uh
we have a very weird structure
so there's four game this is the final
game of today's mini match
um between hikaru and wesley between
napo and carlson now the winner of
today's match
they play again tomorrow uh they play
again tomorrow
and and and and you know if you win
today and lose tomorrow then you play
the blitz playoff that's like what
picard did against mbl yesterday
and so we'll see we'll see
thank you coach grant we also had
a um 100 bits from fizz buzz puzz thank
you so much
all right um now how do we understand
this position what do w what do we look
at
when we look at a position like this um
there is sort of a sequence of of items
that we can go
go through and compare them uh the first
is king safety and you know when you
look at the kings
whose king is safer probably whites
because you can you can understand that
there is a potential for white to play
f3 and you know black has played g5 so
uh well you know black needs to keep an
eye on his king white's king seems
perfectly safe
um then you look at the pawn structure
and definitely well it's not
easy to say well clearly visually
black's pawn structure
looks horrible but he's also got a lot
of pawns in the center that counts for
something
then you look at peace activity okay
black's bishops kind of criss-cross the
board
and white's bishops are both staring
into ponds which is not a good thing
their their kinetic energy is low but
their potential energy is high if you
look at the bishop on g2 it could deploy
itself to h3
uh this move f3 that i mentioned wesley
could prepare it because if you play f3
immediately
then what might end up happening is you
might end up losing the pawn on d4 i'm
not even sure that's good for black
because look at black's puns
now uh let's see what wesley did he
played rook c1 and
hikaru plays g4 yeah so hikara trying to
discourage wesley from playing f3 and
also
uh he's setting up a potential attack
here on the king side
which is kind of interesting now wesley
what is he doing he's aiming
his pieces down the c file so wesley
could already consider taking
decaro has to take with this spawn and
well
wesley could take this one but hikaru
would take that one and now if you look
at the bishop on g2 it's permanently
buried
and that is not a situation you want to
find yourself in so that's kind of out
of the question
i think for wesley he could take and
maybe now defend or maybe he could try
queen c6
uh kind of forking the bishop in the
pawn and then you take a better pawn a
juicier one
this seems a little bit more palatable
but still i mean leaving yourself with a
bishop like this
especially when it's counterpart is also
kind of dull
is is a little bit a little bit
suspicious so i would still consider
going f3 if i were wesley
i would i would totally still consider
going f3 just to like untangle my pieces
out of this this this morass that they
find themselves in
you could also take and go rook fe1
preemptively defend the pawn
and and try to aim for that pawn on cc i
don't like this though because
if you look very carefully at the pawn
on f2 that pawn becomes weak
and black could attack it and this is
right up hikaru's alley these kinds of
positions
so that's an sat where el mores
yeah that that's like a swamp i don't
know why i didn't just say swamp
um well probably because you went to
stamford who
yeah um but anyways
let's see what happens now
let's see what happens now so f3
is is what i'm kind of anticipating i
mean it's very hard to predict and let
me refresh so the clock start ticking
it's very hard to predict uh these what
happens in these kinds of positions
there's so many different ways to
approach
these kinds of positions um
and e3 by wesley huh interesting
so he's he's basically said i'm not
going f3 at all
uh and he's going for a different
strategy to
activate the bishop i think what he's
going for
what he's going for is moving the rook
out of f1 and then going bishop f1 so he
wants to deploy his bishop like this
right
uh the downside of that is once you move
your rook away from f1 you weaken the
pawn on f2
so hikaru might be eyeing something like
this hikara might also be eyeing
a rook lift followed by a queen lift and
going after the h21 this is a very
typical way of attacking
wesley has gone bishop a3 and hikaru
goes
okay so he goes h5 he wants to open up
the h file i think hikar's intentions
are very clear
and wesley's gonna have to do something
fast because if he lets cecaro open the
h vowel
and you know this is going to take
hikaru a while to get all his pieces to
the h file
but um but if he does that then you
could get checkmated in two moves i mean
if you get a lot of queen on h2
uh you could get checkmated very quickly
so if i were wesley i'd start
considering exchange sacrifices i mean
i'd start considering pretty drastic
measures
uh to try to open the position up before
black gets all his pieces to
to the king side maybe you move your
rook first i mean maybe he's got time
for this
uh but very quickly he's got to take on
d5 and open stuff up
he does exactly that now here's the
problem and this is what i think wesley
might not have anticipated
in this position icaru can already take
with the e pawn and that rook on f6 at
moonlights is a defender for the pawn
and it's going to still go to h6 and the
third thing that's annoying here for
wesley is this bishop on a6 is
stopping the king from escaping so
bishop
h6 instead by hikaru he's yeah like i
said there's many ways to attack here
it's hard to predict exactly what
will be chosen so what hikaru is doing
maybe is is he's not hurrying
uh queenie two they're playing very fast
i i'm not entirely sure
what it is that both players are are so
in a rush about
i mean they're it's bishop c8 um
okay so hikaru i guess was defending
against some queen a5 ideas and maybe
rerouting the bishop to d7 to give some
more
beef to that pawn on c6
queen to b4 by wesley uh where is this
battery going well maybe he's going for
queen e7 he's trying to trade queens
uh and as we discussed because black is
the one trying to attack on the king's
side
even though i mis-evaluated the king
safety earlier i thought black's king
was
less safe but in light of what's
happened even though and this is a
typical paradox that people sometimes
get confused
it is true that black's king is more
open per se
right but um the analogy that i like to
give in these situations
is you know that famous case of a tree
falling in a forest and nobody hears it
so did the tree make a sound now the
same goes for king safety if your
king could be wide open it could be the
emperor without any clothes
okay and it's this you know you wake up
in your apartment you live alone
you know do you you know you you can go
half a day without putting your clothes
on and
that's not improper but then if you have
a roommate
you know you're not he's not gonna
remain your roommate if you do that
uh so it's all about whether there are
pieces on the side of the board
where there are weaknesses if a weakness
is inaccessible then it's not really a
weakness for the time being
on the other hand white's got more pawns
that analogy
was interesting that yeah but um i
i put down but but here's the thing guys
nobody's gonna forget this now you can
laugh but now everybody's gonna remember
how to evaluate king safety and that is
my ultimate goal here
is to help people is to help people
remember these concepts
so wesley's got more pawns on the kings
side
but black has more pieces there so black
is the one attacking wesley's piling up
on the c file hikaru finally gets his
rook to h6 which we kind of anticipated
happening
and and he's got this long-term idea now
bringing the queen to h5
all right
is it true that icarus semi retired from
classical well i think it's going that
way
um i also think that
there have been no classical tournaments
over the board right so this
is the equivalent right now of classical
chess i don't think hikara is going to
retire permanently from classical when
it resumes in full force
i think he's going to tone things down i
think things are going well for him on
the twitch front
and uh you know it's it's his choice
entirely so
uh you know he's it's we'll see we'll
see
i don't think i wouldn't jump to any
conclusions uh or make any
uh assumptions i will let him do the
talking
um and again i i don't like talking
about this because it always brings on
the kind of conversations which i don't
like to have on my stream
uh but i do feel the need to clarify
this from time to time
because there's new people in my stream
and i appreciate that
but to those thinking that there is some
sort of a beef between me and icaru
there never was
there isn't and uh my guess is that
there never will be
we are both competitors i'm say this in
the
best interpretation of the word we i
wouldn't say our rivals but you know
we go for bullet rankings and i'm number
one and he's number he's much stronger
than me
but uh you know we have the spirit of
competition but there's a lot of mutual
respect
and uh there's no need to make anything
other than what it is
out of that okay so i just wanted to
make that very clear
uh we definitely troll each other we
don't see eye to eye
on everything uh you know i've had my
issues with
how he's acted and i'm sure he's had his
issues with how i've acted and that's
totally fine
but that doesn't mean there can exist
tremendous amount of mutual respect
which there does
and that's all i'll say on the topic
because there's no need to discuss it
further
okay it's healthy it's an atmosphere of
healthy competition
we have a healthy working relationship
so that's that's all there is to it
um yeah so
uh back to the game robert is making a
very good point
i don't know why i should listen to this
gm hess character but this gm has
character
actually made a good point the bishop on
g2 is biting on granite but there was a
romanian grandmaster
many years ago who said bad bishops
defend good pawns
well if you want to extend this quote
bad bishops also defend good squares
and if you prognosticate a scenario i'm
just going to make a couple of random
moves
where hicaro gets his pieces on the h
file
what's very important about this bishop
is that it defends the h1 square
and and this really makes black stuck in
terms of delivering check
checkmate because the king is virtually
always going to be guaranteed
at least a new lease on life once it
gets to f1 now hikaru could try to
circumvent this by tripling on the h
file
and then there's a pretty common queen
sacrifice here
so something to this effect sorry
something to this effect would be
checkmate
the problem is uh wesley could preempt
this by running with his king before
hikaru gets his queen to h1
yeah shuba is right okay um
i don't think house knows what the hell
he's talking about but
anyways uh that's a good point i must
be grudgingly admitted so wesley is
allowing himself to
uh to expand his influence over the
queen side he's pushing his pawns up
he's eyeing some b5 ideas
and uh it may very well be that ricardo
has run out of fuel
to make this attack work uh in the true
sense of the word
uh and in addition the lines that i that
i
showed are not valid because as soon as
you move the queen away you give up c7
so hikaru is gonna have to solve that
problem as well
i think things have gone wrong i'm not
reading i'm just flipping through
absentmindedly through the book i
recommended yesterday
i have a habit of this uh as you guys
know i just flip through pages
randomly while while commentating while
doing streaming
okay
mr gambini that was a lucid intelligent
well thought out objection overruled
from my favorite movie so is it possible
that two utes
excuse me what was that two what d did
you say utes
what is a ute okay uh so b5 here we go
um wesley strikes on the queen side and
he makes things go
boom okay so what's going on here takes
takes takes
you would take this one and this would
be in white's crosshairs
and the position collapses and this is
what i mentioned right black's king
was safe by virtue of the fact that
white had no pieces attacking it now
white finally has an artery a direct
artery to black's king
uh and and there will be hell to pay i
mean rook t7 and rook c7 already wins
the queen and that's a direct result of
the king being
completely uh disrobed let's say by
the pawns that have abandoned him i was
looking for a different word but
so i came home in the evening and i
disrobed
that's a pretty funny word to disrobe
how much disrobing have you done in your
life um
all right uh i don't know why why all
these closed analogies today
but anyways queens well because the king
is undefended i guess that's the source
of it um
the king going yeah that's right hgh
hikara opens the h file which he has to
try to do but it's not going to be
enough like like
this grand master has character
mentioned you can do this
until tomorrow morning but you're not
going to deliver anything other than
an empty check on h1 the rook's going to
be captured
um yeah a judge would disrobe
so all right i am wearing fans for the
time for the record
and um what was the name of i'm looking
for a particular person that
um
yeah i i will not be participating in
any zoom calls anytime soon
okay um
let's throw any illusions of that in the
garbage tubing okay uh so queen before
and now in this position now in this
position
well again hikaru is trying to keep his
position together
b takes c6 as possible wesley can also
play c takes d5 uh
and yeah this i mean okay hikaru is
trying to keep his position together
even if wesley takes on c6 which he
which he just did
hikara will ignore the spawn he's not
gonna take back because that would do
what's bidding for him and
open the c file um
and but but but even without
even with the c file closed uh again
it's very important to point out here
that uh
that the h file isn't going to give
black any immediate benefits so
wesley's going to have to find a way to
enhance the pressure on the cpu let's
look at carlson nepo
yeah so nepo carlson has been a
fascinating game as you guys can see
a berlin with rookie one in a must-win
game for an apple pretty interesting
choice
and wow okay uh i think that
we didn't miss out on this game thank
you 42 for the sub
wow uh the format is well if icaru loses
today's matchup they will
again play the same format tomorrow
sorry this is interesting
yeah so this is a dead draw and magnus
is going to pull it off i think nepo
is finding it hard to recover
after that previous game and i don't
blame him that was that was a
a very very good chance for him but all
credit to magnus so let's go back to
hicarro against
so i think that's the interesting game
right now
okay um actually the more i look at this
position
the more i realize uh it's it's hard for
wesley to make
progress here uh because uh because
again the c file is closed white would
like his own pawn to disappear imagine
if you could take the pawn on c6
uh then white would have again a direct
line of fire to black's king via c7 but
as it stands cecaro could just do
nothing
uh and and i don't see a good way for
wesley to make progress remember
if you try to activate this bishop the
moment you do that ikara is going to
shift his queen to h8
that bishop is going to have to go right
back in order to keep the h1 square
covered
rook to a8 by hikaru he's just attacking
the queen
the issue is and wesley doesn't mind a
draw at all because he will win the mini
match
hikaru needs to win this game and that
is going to be a big problem i just
don't see
a single way that he can even attempt to
generate chances in this position
um and and that's that's the main issue
here wesley
can modify his strategy because a draw
suits him completely
okay
yeah so it's it's very locked i i don't
see any chances realistically for black
wesley is dipping a little bit on the
clock
uh but but but this is the kind of
position you could play fast
okay anybody have any questions about uh
this position or or the games i'm happy
to also answer them i'm not trying to
just
make this a one-way street um bishop e4
would be too much right you would
you would be giving up your bishop and
in return you would be getting
sort of an intangible benefit right
you'd be getting
a a rank for the rook but that wouldn't
be enough to justify such a
such a sacrifice uh if i were hikaru
trying to win i mean maybe you could try
rook 82 just something provocative like
the way that these positions can
sometimes be won
is you provoke the opponent into into
something
over ambitious right wesley thinks ah
you know now i can win
and and he makes a misjudgment so i
would play provocatively if i were
hikaru but
it's easier said than done because rook
a2 is that doesn't even do much right
it just sits there and you could also
chase the rook away you could go rook to
c2
and offer the trade of rooks which is
totally fine for white
but uh i would do something in that
spirit uh the other thing i would
consider doing if i were hikaru is try
to triple on the d
file so maybe queen to g5 and then
rocket shield and queen hi now we
discussed that even in this situation
wesley could evacuate his king at a
moment's notice
but if he does that sorry if he does
that then you could put a rook on h2
and so i would probably try to do that
instead yeah i would go queen f6 or
queen g5
try to get the rook over to h8 uh that
might involve giving up the c7 pawn
that's the issue
uh but but so be it i mean again you
have nothing to lose here
loss is literally equivalent to a draw
uh bob leno you're absolutely right i
mean you just called this idea
yeah so that's well you do have bishop
e4 but but that might be part of the
what i mentioned right maybe you give
the spawn up and buy yourself some time
because remember this bishop is
vulnerable and it's the key
to the defense of white skin
okay
so we'll see what hikaru does he's
definitely thinking about all these
ideas he's thinking about how to make
them work
he's got really only one shot oh queen
f3 is also an idea by the way
and uh a winter remix you're mentioning
a very
very beautiful concept which actually
happened in one of my old games so let's
if you if you put on the board this you
can go queen to f3
and by virtue of the x-ray you win
because the bishop has to take the queen
and there's now no stopping the
checkmate very nice call
so that's another thing that hikaru
could consider queen f6 followed by rook
uh followed by rook a to h8 uh that's a
really cool tactic and
uh the funny thing is i had a game a
couple of years ago which i've shown on
stream in a lesson with nicola where
i had exactly the same idea in
in in that game and i'll just show you
guys really really quickly while hikaru
was contemplating his move
so i had the following
position okay i had the following
position one of my games against friedel
and here i played queen f3 and if he
would have snuck his bishop on g7
i had this idea of going queen to f6
exactly the same concept right
sacrificing your queen to establish a
pawn on f6 and to eliminate
uh a defender of the h8 square now it's
a different execution here there you're
putting a rook on h8
here i'm putting a upon an h8 but yeah
you can see that the patterns
the tactical patterns are often shared
between several different kinds of
attacks
and that's always a good good thing to
notice when you're trying to learn and
you're trying to pick up on ideas
um so that's that's one thing to point
out here
hikaru continuing to contemplate his
options
as um nepo and carlson continue to play
thank you text chess appreciate it
months my man well thank you
i fish you really appreciate it thank
you that's very sweet
okay uh geary is much stronger than me
i again think in terms of world rankings
i'm like 150 geary is like top five
so i might be stronger in blitz and
bullet but that's basically it
that doesn't count for anything um
now let's see what he car does here he
he continues to contemplate this
critical moment i
we're anticipating queen f6 i don't
think he's going to be able to resist
this idea wesley will see the idea of
queen f3
another thing to point out here is that
queen f6 might meet with
queen b7 right a fork against the rook
and the pawn
and if you stubbornly pursue this idea
uh this doesn't work anymore and there's
a very interesting reason why could
somebody tell me why in this position
black no longer
has imminent checkmate on h what
defensive resource does white now have
uh in this position and think about what
the mechanism is
behind this checkmate you could go queen
e5
and you could just take the rook and uh
black's attack has been
disrobed there's rook h1 and it's no
longer a threat in white just promotes a
spawn good job
hicaro has gone rook a6 after much
contemplation he's decided not to embark
on that idea
which surprises me but i guess there was
something about it that he didn't like i
guess he just couldn't make it work in
his mind
and remember that wesley is not someone
who falls for
any kind of superficial tactical ideas
so
a realistic decision by hikar maybe
another strategy that he might be
adhering to
hear me out for a second hikaru might be
saying this okay wesley has no easy way
to make progress so what he's going to
do is try to bleed wesley's clock
until he's got two or three minutes and
then he's going to all of a sudden
re-embark on that plan uh so
he might be trying to bank on wesley
getting nervous and thinking for a long
overthinking things
trying to manage his position you can
already see that it's bearing some fruit
but
it could backfire because wesley could
find a way to trade a bunch of pieces
and that's exactly what he's done here
he's sacrificing his pawn back but in
return he's trading rooks and he's
opening the c
file both of which are benefiting him
again
let us not forget he's trying to make a
draw what i'm not sure about he can go
even rook c5 immediately in fact i think
that's what he's going to do you don't
need to give up the c file at all
and uh you could you could now you have
very nice pressure on this pawn
and black has to go all in for passive
defense
and that's exactly what wesley has done
he's gone rook a to c5
i don't think hikaru can take the rook i
think hikaru has to go rook b6 he's got
to keep as many pieces on the board as
possible
but this is exactly what we discussed
remember i said white wants to take his
own pawn
well he's gotten black to take his pawn
and now all of a sudden and that's what
he car has done but queen a5 or queen c3
and white's got tremendous pressure on
the c7 pawn that's the direct artery we
talked about rook to b5 okay so wesley
instead deciding to trade the rooks
which is just as sensible because he's
got another rook remaining on c1
again you could have a repetition of
moves here that would be entirely in
wesley's favor because the draw wins him
the mini match
what icaru could also try to do is go
rook h to c6
uh because it's all about the c file
here and if you take and go rook c5
yeah i don't know this is just a draw so
uh this this just doesn't look
winnable at all for hikaru but maybe i
mean he always finds a way to
to mix things up so that's that's one of
his strengths uh and he's desperately
trying to do that here
okay give me a second
i'm finally allowing myself a cup of
coffee today
yeah so takes in rook b6 makes sense
we're anticipating queen c5 or queen a5
something like that
okay so if you have queen c5 there we go
and uh what hikaru might have to do and
that would spell disaster
is c6 and he's done it and he has no
choice there's no other way to defend
the pawn
and why is this disaster because now the
rook is tied down to the pawn wesley
could finally
and that's what he does he can finally
liberate his bishop
why because it's the same analogy hikaru
now can no longer
maneuver his pieces to the hra wesley
has judged
that hikaru just literally has no way to
get his rook to the age file so the
bishop is home free
you could finally activate it and have
it be a working member of society on e2
and you might be looking at this and
saying how does he know that well if you
just look at the rook on b6 how is it
going to ever get to the h file in a
timely manner
it's not right it's going to have to go
to b8 but if it goes to b then you drop
c6 and if you drop c6
then white's pieces stream in via the c
file
so a very very subtle approach to the
position by wesley and
i think this is going to yield uh the
benefit of the draw
uh again if he was playing a classical
game here uh just in an individual
tournament
he would be playing this for a win but
as it stands he has the benefit of the
draw
so yeah this is this is going to be very
very hard for hikara to create any
realistic chances in
okay i was never in this tournament
and uh i wanted to thank everybody we
have over a thousand people once again
for joining the commentary this morning
i appreciate it we're over 4 000 subs
which is amazing uh we hit that
yesterday for the first time in my
streaming career so
in the spirit of thanksgiving i'm
extremely grateful for this community
and
everybody for all of your sweet messages
and all of your support
so thanks everybody and hope you're
enjoying thank you big evo for the 100
bits
yeah so bishop e8 to untie the rook
was suggested but then i can go bishop
e2 and attack the pun
so you're not going it's all pawns and
no talk all talking no pawns what's the
what's benewatt say about the kara khan
is it all all pawns and no something i
forget what it is
maybe somebody get all pawns and no hope
no hope no hope yeah
all pawns and no hope so this is all
pawns and no hope
and yeah there is very little hope
remaining of a draw for hikaru
i'm sorry of a win for hikaru
and yeah it's it's it's probably going
to be a draw now checking quickly back
to
jan against carlson i mean if anybody
can win this position it seems to be
magnus
uh you could i mean this is just magnus
is not going to lose this you could even
take and go king d6 and
just walk the king over because rook g7
could be met with rook to g8
and you just have a dead draw let me
refresh against the clock start ticking
um i think he was talking about the karo
khan though to be honest
okay rook that's exactly what he's done
i think he's gonna go knd6
and we're gonna see a draw in this game
magnus wins the first mini match
putting nepo in a must-win situation for
tomorrow's winning match
all right uh which i will try to
commentate we will see
uh i don't know if i will manage to do
so
but we will see if i can get at least
one or two hours in
i've got my some of my family coming
over tomorrow for
for the day so i'll have to be be free
the second half of the day
um well my my brother and well i've got
a bunch
well some couple people coming over
you will commentate uh well i don't know
about that then i might have to
commentate if if hess is gonna take over
man uh i don't know about that
what book am i no i'm not reading any
book i'm just again i'm flipping
absolutely through the pages of a book
called
the path to chess mastery it's a soviet
book from the from 1970.
nakamura has drawn yes so all right so
we we had a draw
oh sorry that's the wrong game yeah
they've agreed to a draw because
and and people might be wondering why
did he carry off for a draw here you
know he
it's because he has no chances of
winning this game
none you know it's it's there's just no
way and he's got not a single idea and
and so he acquiesced to that and offered
a draw
which makes perfect sense so he loses
the first mini match as he did against
mbl
which puts him in a must-win situation
for tomorrow
and um and uh that means
that well he's surmounted this before
but wesley's got to be happy with the
result of this and nepo carlson also
draw
so both games end at the same time and
magnus wins their first mini match
which puts napo in a must-win scenario a
tall order for both of them
but you know that's what makes this
tournament fun everybody's capable of
[Music]
anything